hey everyone i'm lucy and i'm a
solutions architect working at amazon
web services hey everyone i'm alistair
and i'm a cloud architect working in
amazon web services today we're going to
be talking about the difference between
a solutions architect and a cloud
architect and how to figure out which
one is right for you
quick pause this video is sponsored by
network teams networkings is your
one-stop educational platform for it
courses whether you're studying for an
aws certification or want to improve
your skills in networking and devops i
would recommend checking out this
platform they provide you with access to
live online classes taught by
experienced engineers you can see here
that there's even courses based on
specific career paths for example you
can enroll in this course if you'd like
to become a cloud architect at the end
of each course you get awarded with a
certificate of completion which is
pretty cool if you're interested in
finding out more about networkings i'll
leave a link to the website in the video
description below now let's get back to
the video so as i said to start off with
do you want to give a bit of intro about
yourself and also explain what the role
of a cloud architect does at aws sure so
i'm an associate cloud architect in our
public sector proserv team what i do in
the end is deliver projects for our
customers i'm very much a customer
facing role where we go in we understand
the customers needs and we actually go
and build out the solutions to help our
businesses and our customers solve their
problems so on any day-to-day basis i
could be coding up in python working
with lambda designing larger
architectures or working with
organizations to figure out what people
and processes they need to actually get
the job done lucy how do you think that
varies to solution architects
yeah so solutions architects are quite
similar in some ways we also interact
with customers and we help them with
basically getting into aws and migrating
their services from on-premises to aws
as well as helping them modernize their
architectures but what we do is
we are more high level we're trusted
technical advisors for the customers as
they go along their cloud journey we do
things like helping them review their
architectures making sure it's well
architected and following best practices
we also do things like customer
enablement so we help customers learn
about how they can use aws in order for
them to meet their business and
technical goals and so this is i think
probably the main distinction right
between a solutions architect and a
cloud architect so this brings us to the
similarities and differences of a
solutions architect versus a cloud
architect alice said let me ask this to
you first what do you think are the main
distinctions between the two and what
are the biggest similarities we're both
customer facing and in the end we want
to get the best for our customers but
one thing on a day-to-day basis i
probably will work with one or two
customers to deliver specific results
and
opportunities for the customers whether
that be putting together an application
designing a landing zone or actually
coding up something that can be tangibly
placed whereas you're probably thinking
many many different paths that the
customer can go and achieve their
business goals
yep that's exactly right i agree with
the similarities and the differences i
think as a solutions architect it
depends on the team that you're in but
typically you would work with more than
one or two customers like for example
for me since i work with smaller medium
businesses i work with honestly hundreds
of different customers to try and
understand their business problems and
technical problems and how i can help
them build in high-level architecture so
that it helps them you know think
long-term and not just address their
short-term goals but also help them
achieve what they want for their
business in the long run and i think
that really shows in the differences on
our day-to-day jobs most times i try to
focus on one customer per day i'll start
the morning in a stand-up where we're
working with the customer team to
actually understand what everybody's
working on we'll provide some directions
to them and some advice but in the end
we actually want to help enable those
customers to build out and with us just
being the trusted advisor i work
throughout the day i may build some
things may speak to some more people and
think about the strategic direction
and at the end of the day we actually
have hopefully built and deployed
something and then like all of us here
at aws we're trying to hire and develop
the best so
admin time comes in for us to help hire
new people train up learn new concepts
so that we can continually enable our
customers to build and develop on the
latest best practice
definitely that's one of the
similarities as well in aws as a
solutions architect we do play a part as
well in helping hire and develop the
best so mentoring other people and also
receiving mentorship as well so that's
something i think is quite common just
within a lot of roles in aws actually
it's not just about talking with
customers and just doing our work also
thinking about how we're able to help
the future generation of leaders you
know the future and incoming cloud
architects and solutions architects so
speaking of the future generation and
helping people you know get into aws how
do you think people can choose between
the two roles so in the end like we've
discussed our roles are very similar
they're both customer facing but i think
the main difference and the main
differentiator when somebody should
choose a role is how much they want to
dive deep and how willing they are to
think outside the box when they come
across problems because in the end we
need to make sure that our systems work
with very complex organization
infrastructure so if you get to a point
where something doesn't work you need to
think about ideas to how you can still
achieve the customer goals while still
working within the confines of what
opportunities we have there so if you'd
like to get in dive deep ask questions
you don't really need to know all the
answers but in the end that's where you
can come and join our team and have a
lot of customer impact wow seems like
we're going to have a lot of future
cloud architects so if you're someone
who is more interested in understanding
system design and architecture but don't
want to get involved with the actual
implementation and diving into the code
to help people actually implement it
then a solutions architect role could be
something to look forward to so the
solutions architect role would also be
for someone who really wants to be
interacting with customers on a
day-to-day basis to help them understand
their business problems because at the
end of the day we have so many aws
services and as a solutions architect
it's our role to help customers decide
what's best for them and you know what
combination of services will be best for
their situation all right so this brings
us to the end of this video if you have
any questions for us drop it down the
comments below please remember to give
this video a like and subscribe to this
channel to see more videos like this
thank you so much alice there for your
time today thanks for having me